[Applaudissements]
et à monsieur daniel fasquelle merci
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre il ya maintenant 100 jours le
23 juin dernier les britanniques voter
par référendum leur sortie l'union
européenne cette décision lourde de
conséquence appelait une réaction forte
de la part de la france vous même vous
avez déclaré dix jours après le break
site welcome in paraissent venez
investir en france mais depuis non
seulement vous avez été incapable de
convaincre les autres pays d'union de
relancer la construction européenne mais
en plus je n'avais pris aucun texte
aucune mesure réellement convaincante
pour rendre le pays plus attractif
dimanche dernier les britanniques ont
franchi une nouvelle étape theresa may
affirmant que la grande bretagne
voulaient une rupture franche avec
l'union européenne d'où quatre questions
1 de nombreuses entreprises de nombreux
cadres de nombreux investisseurs
étrangers ont préféré depuis quatre ans
la grande bretagne à la france elle et
vous enfin réorienter en profondeur
votre politique fiscale et économique
pour restaurer la compétitivité de notre
pays 2 alors que la grande bretagne veut
durcir sa politique en matière de flux
migratoires allez vous enfin déclencher
l'article 23 des accords du touquet qui
prévoit une renégociation en cas de
circonstances exceptionnelles
où allez-vous continuer à envoyer un peu
partout en france dix réfugiés qui eux
veulent aller en grande bretagne 3 on
sait qu'en partie une partie des
activités de la city pourrait se
redéployer sur le continent les experts
évoquent cent mille emplois quelles
initiatives allez vous prendre pour que
paris ne soit pas écartée au profit
d'autres places financières 4 enfin quel
siège autorités européennes installées
outre-manche voulez-vous attiré en
france bref monsieur le premier ministre
alors que madame theresa may 2 promet un
break seat dure elle et vous encore une
fois lui opposer une france molle ou
prendrez-vous enfin toute la mesure de
l'enjeu que représente cet événement
politique économique le plus important
depuis la chute du mur de berlin nous
attendons vos réponses monsieur coué
unissent merci monsieur pascal la parole
est à monsieur michel sapin min de
l'économie et des finances
sur les ondes à messieurs les escales
une bonne partie de votre question vous
en conviendrez touchette à la question
du non seulement du bric site mais de
ses conséquences éventuelles pour la
france pour l'europe dans les activités
en particulier financières et c'est donc
à celle là qu'est cette partie là de
votre question que je souhaite répondre
vous le savez nous n'avons pas souhaité
je le pense aussi vous non plus que le
peuple britannique se prononce en faveur
du bric site il l'a fait il doit
maintenant en tirer toutes les
conséquences nous trouvons que la
premier ministre prendre beaucoup de
temps peut-être un peu trop de temps
avant d'engager des négociations
mais si ça lui permet de se préparer ça
nous permet aussi du côté européen et du
côté français de se préparer monsieur
monsieur le député vous avez je trouve
de manière inconsidérée en parlant d'une
angleterre durée d'une france molle vous
avez en quelque sorte porter un jugement
presque injurié l'ensemble des acteurs
français de la place de paris qui se
sont immédiatement mobilisés pour faire
en sorte que l'attractivité de paris
déjà aujourd'hui puisse être avancé et
permettre de convaincre nous n'allons
pas les contraindre de convaincre un
certain nombre de grands sièges
financiers installés à londres de venir
s'installer ou de transférer des
activités en france nous avons ouvert
des guichets qui se rassemblent la
région ile de france avec madame
pécresse comme la mairie de paris avec
madame il galgo comme l'ensemble des
ministères et des services concernés
pour faciliter les choses pour faciliter
la réimplantation et l'accueil d'un
certain nombre de ceux qui travaillent
là bas nous proposons dans cette loi de
finances peut-être allez-vous la beauté
un certain nombre de dispositions pour
renforcer l'attractivité et faciliter
l'installation de jeunes ou de moins
jeunes qui travaillent en grande
bretagne et qui voudraient venir en
france vous avez encore quelques temps
pour changer votre jugement est votée la
loi de finances et en votant la loi de
finances vous montrerez que vous
n'appartenez pas à la droite molle
merci la parole l'état monsieur
dominique pauthe